hey guys how's it going my name is
philip molina and this is i see me I see
me we're going to immediately gonna
react to the footage that we saw come
out of Comic Con it wasn't supposed to
be a trailer but it basically is a
Justice League trailer that nobody was
really expecting and there's definitely
a lot to break down so we wanted to get
this out as fast as we could so we're
kind of gonna riff on it and let you
know the things we saw I'm gonna point
out everything that we notice and stuff
that might explain some of things you
saw based off what we know from the
comics yeah definitely so let's get
right into it there is a stranger who
comes to this village from the sea he
comes in the winter when people are
hungry brings fish comes on the king
tide that was last night
talk talk talk all right so this is
Bruce Wayne
last we left them help me find the
others like you perhaps they don't wanna
be found was on a mission to assemble a
sort of team and here he is doing it
he's a dusty village looking for a man
who brings people fish in the middle of
winter no Bruce has a beard by the way
so it wasn't the next day but Ben
Affleck does grow pretty sick beards
pretty quickly so it could be quickly
after the death of Superman and notice
how Bruce says that whoever this is
comes in on the king tide and the king
tide is like a specific term it means a
really high tide it only happens a
couple times a year so I think it's a
reference to that but it might also be a
reference to the actual idea of a king
which Arthur curry is Aquaman he's king
of Atlantis or at least he's supposed to
be he's got he's the rightful heir to
the iron but not iron water thrown down
there huh so would make sense that he
would come in on the king tide and we're
thinking this is more the classic
version of Arthur curry that we know
from the comics is not to classic cuz
that one is a real bag of nothing but
the basic version of Aquaman is that
he's half human half atlante and he was
born on land but he becomes heir to the
throne of Atlantis but he still cares
about humans he still has a human heart
and he brings them fish in the dead of
the winter and he drinks booze when he's
pissed off just like a normal everyday
king of Atlantis human who has white
eyes just you know that kind of like
normal everyday guy I bet his heart is
also not working with hot dog but anyway
let's move
I believe that enemies coming from far
away I'm looking for warriors this
stranger we come in on Icky Thump by the
white stripes which just sounds badass
it feels like what DC is doing now is
like oh let's just decide to be cool
kind of like your mom's advice to you
when you're a nerd but then we go to
this forest and we see some sort of
ancient man
maybe Vikings is my guess and they're
bearing what we think could be a mother
box if you don't know what a mother box
is it's a really important piece of
technology and another hell dimension
that's run by this guy Darkseid he's a
huge deal we'll get to him later but
let's talk about what is happening with
this box probably now so if you remember
back in Batman vs Superman there was
that deleted scene that came out online
was in the extended edition with Lex
Luthor inside the Kryptonian ship
communing with this guy Steppenwolf he's
probably gonna be the major villain in
Justice League the first part and notice
in that scene you saw him with these
three mother boxes the story behind that
is based on rumor around the Justice
League is that 30,000 years ago there
was this big war for earth bought by the
Amazonians the Atlanteans and man
teaming up against Darkseid now Darkseid
is the guy who commands Stefan will
stepanova is like his lieutenant so
they're thinking that in Justice League
Steppenwolf will be trying to return to
Earth to reclaim these three mother
boxes as for where these three mother
boxes are right now one looks like it
might be in the ground somewhere but it
kind of seemed like maybe cyborg was
being made based on the footage in
Batman vs Superman using a mother box
maybe maybe the Amazonian still have one
I think it's gonna be a little bit like
search for the mother boxes I'm gonna go
ahead and call out yes it's pretty
similar to a bunch of searches for some
stones by a guy who's real big and he
looks a lot like Darkseid but who cares
it might be awesome alright we also get
this quick shot of Wonder Woman with her
shield and if you notice this is not the
same shield that was in the other recent
trailer from comic-con
Wonder Woman she has a different shield
it's in a totally different time period
like a hundred years before when this
takes place there's a moment to point
out we did a whole breakdown of the
Wonder Woman trailer and everything
that's going on there so check that
video out when you have a second then
you don't want this one but moving on
and this for real real quick I want to
point out this shot of
Arthur curry when he's walking towards
the waves the waves just crash into him
feel like this guy is a real rugged
ladies man I feel like that soundly
these greet him they're so turned on in
there so moving up others like him I'm
building an alliance to defend us it's
very important that I see this man so
here we see more of our big players
Barry Allen Victor stone aka cyborg he's
wearing this gotham city university
letterman jacket he's a quarterback
number seven notice that the colors of
that jacket are black and yellow those
are the same colors the Gotham Knights
pro football team so it's cool to see
Gotham City has consistent color schemes
across different director universities
but they stick to that Viking yellow bag
over getting your picture stung by the
way he was a football player in the
comics he had scientists parent said
well he's in this he has an issue I
don't want to spoil too much he just
ends up in not great shape and then his
parents are able to kind of bring him
back into good shape by using some of
the technology but what's interesting is
that in the more recent comics what does
this to him what they are able to use to
bring them back to life it's related to
dark side and those mother boxes in that
world so it could be one of these things
like a deal with the devil kind of
situation where you know you get back
what you really want but at what cost
and if that scene where they save his
life is part of a Batman vs Superman
notice how in this shot Victor stone
cyborg doesn't have any of his metal
technology on top of them he's still
just an athlete so I'm wondering if what
we're seeing is part of a flashback or
is just taking place before when he gets
his powers yeah it's worth noting by the
way that cyborg and flash are very young
here I think that they're trying to set
those characters up with their kind of
origin story here even though the other
characters we kind of were forced into
getting nothing really quickly these I
think they're gonna go ahead and plant
some of those earlier scenes that said
we're gonna see in the moment Flash
already seems to be pretty active in his
heroics watch check it out
[Music]
Barry Allen first way you said that like
it explains why there's a total stranger
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair here we're seeing Bruce
Wayne recruiting Barry Allen flash to
the team and just like we saw Bruce
trying to recruit Aquaman I feel like
since Bruce is handling those two heroes
I wonder if Wonder Woman is going to be
the one to bring cyborg into the team
right and then let's also take a look
here this place is awesome it looks like
maybe some sort of former or Kade or
something you can see in the background
I test your strength game so probably
one of these really old places maybe
like an old funhouse kind of also
reminiscent up at society's hideout in
mr. robot and I'm also wondering does
flash actually live in this place you
can see some of his clothes off to the
side but actually there's so much to
look at here so let's actually zoom in
on this place and see everything we can
learn first up we see tons of books on
shelves now remember Barry Allen since
he can move super fast he can also read
and process information super fast so
he's a speed reader and he's trying to
learn pretty much everything he can
we've seen books on XML coding that's
like computer language coding there's
also a bunch of political biographies so
this guy's just trying to become a
Renaissance man and use his powers to
make himself a better educated person
yeah well I have a theory that he's
trying to like learn everything for a
reason not just for his ability to solve
a crime that's very inherent to the
flash storyline and all that you learn
about later but also look at these
monitors everywhere there's world maps
and there's also parts of his suit and
he's like testing for aerodynamics he's
clearly trying to be the utmost version
of a hero that he can be quick little
Easter Egg here obviously a lot of you
have pointed this out to me and I think
it's great Rick and Morty is playing in
the background
specifically the episode where summer
makes deals with the devil which came up
earlier and we can see that this is a
scene where X is gonna give it to you
Extra never - yeah they're pulling their
gloves down now I want to point out
something extra here though this whole
section of Barry's Swasey apartment is
dedicated to the design of its costume
you can see his helmet you can see the
chest piece you can see his costume is
right over there and right when the
sequence starts we see the fingerless
gloves that Rick and summer are both
wearing I think that's actually where he
gets the idea for his fingerless gloves
later he just thinks it's cool cuz Rick
and Morty made a look so cool actually
later you
these close-up shots of sketches that
Barry had made designing his costume
kind of like Peter Parker in the first
spider-man movie and remember back in
Batman vs Superman it was hinted that
Lex Luthor might have been the one to
come up with each of these logos for the
Justice League members he used the
lightning bolt and all the other symbols
to label each of the attachments and his
files but now it seems like Barry might
be the one to come up with the logo
himself also check out that that suit
it's on a dummy you can see that but
look by the temple that's a crash-test
dummy I think that means that he's not
just using this as like a creepy
mannequin to scare me at night I think
he's actually putting this suit on this
mannequin through the paces and seeing
if it can deal with SuperSpeed and see
how his body would hold up if they
smacked into something while running and
not paying attention let's move on
he said he'll fight with us more or less
more more or more or less
probably more or less he said no they
said no all right and then this next
section it's actually just like kind of
dedicated more to that Aquaman's
storyline again which by the way no this
is like a scary version of Aquaman kind
of a Mariner who clearly like lives on
the ocean almost like a pirate I'd not
be when people want to attack but
earlier but also to worth noting that
the prominence of Aquaman in this
trailer I think he's actually gonna play
a huge role in the plot specifically I
think that Atlantis is probably gonna
play a huge role of the plot of this
movie and that makes me want to point
out something that is happening right
here beneath our very faces look at
these computer screens and this place
that Bruce and Wonder Woman have found
themselves in it's not the Batcave
actually let's brighten things up a
little bit yeah look at the background
here that wall looks kind of like it's
the hole and then there's this monitor
showing a vessel of some kind at first
we thought that maybe this is Wonder
Woman's invisible jet or maybe they're
in some kind of submarine but then based
off of visits to the Justice League set
this is probably a large jet called the
flying box which is kind of like a maybe
DC equivalent to the Helicarrier from
the Avengers and maybe the Justice
League is gonna use it like the Avengers
did in that movie it'll be their base of
operations
and here's another rumor it could
contain within it like underneath the
Batmobile and maybe even this new bat
vehicle called the Nightcrawler which is
kind of a tank I guess that could maybe
climb up walls it sounds amazing and of
course the name flying fox could of
course be a reference to Lucius Fox who
helps run Wayne Corp and in the Nolan
movies help Batman with all of his tech
this jet could be named after him but I
don't think we've seen Lucius Fox in
this new DC movie universe yet I'm just
hoping that somehow they still bring
back Morgan Freeman in some way like
even if he's just the voice of the
computer or something like even though
he's a computer he would still respond
very slowly but full of wisdom you know
what I mean well the best way to answer
your question would be to ask one back
to you I mean really how often do you
look at a man's shoes what does that
mean computer any well oh gosh I'm just
gonna type instead of talk to Mike
look man I don't know who you are but
whoever you're looking for
[Music]
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification
so here Bruce tosses a Batarang of Barry
Allen and it's kind of like when Peggy
Carter fired the gun in Captain America
yes I think it works and notice that
when Barry looks back and disbelief
what's really going on here is that he's
realizing that Bruce Wayne is Batman he
just threw a Batarang at him only one
person the world can have that that's
that look of disbelief and realization
on Ezra Miller space I guess he could
also be a Gotham evidence locker keeper
probably not have you work in the Gotham
lab yeah also no they said Bruce doesn't
really have a problem revealing his
identity to Barry it's kind of like that
moment when Batman just goes down the
line of everyone in the Justice League
and this outs their refill identity hold
on a second here what about the whole
secret identity thing I mean I trust you
guys but I'm not sure I'm ready that
Wally West Clark Kent
Bruce Wayne showoff
they're facing is just too big to really
care about their hidden identities
amongst each other anymore I also will
point out that Barry Allen does not seem
to work with the police in this version
usually as a forensic scientist but I
guess he's like some sort of hackers or
something instead here also I want to
point out this lightning that's emitting
from flash here I know a lot of you
watch a TV show you're like Barry Allen
to evil he's actually secretly zoom no
they're allowed to use different colors
in the movies and the TV shows but also
just getting into this a little bit that
electric charge is something that in the
TV show that version of Barry Allen had
to like earn up and he's able to
actually throw that lightning there's a
really awesome moment where zoom catches
that lightning and in on the TV show but
here the fact that he's building up this
charge and stuff that's almost like a
side power that flash has the ability to
create electricity I think it could be
actually a big part of something he's
able to do in this movie so I think
maybe flash won't just be a speedster he
might use this power of harnessing
electricity at some point in the movie
there definitely are a lot of sparks in
his section foreshadowing
some sort of electrical abilities
real quick I want to point out that you
can actually figure out how fast flash
is moving here we learned about this
from the science of so this row lasts
about twenty one second now if you know
that really good knife throwers can
throw a knife anywhere between 22 and 30
miles an hour and come on we're talking
about peak human here Bruce Wayne so
we'll say 30 miles an hour well if you
take that and then you look and you see
the Batarang takes about two turns when
it reaches Barry so people that have
actually thrown real Batarang they've
found that each turn of a Batarang means
it's traveled about three paces and the
US Army defines a pace is about thirty
inches so that means based on these
rotations these two are standing
something like 15 feet apart so if the
Batarang was going 30 miles an hour and
it traveled 15 feet that means in
Bruce's time that took about point three
four seconds or greater forty
milliseconds that's about the time it
takes a human to blink so if we saw that
throw last 21 seconds but it really only
took three hundred and forty
milliseconds then the flash is moving 62
times faster than normal human speed
that means that at this pace which I
really doubt it's even his fastest pace
it would take him over an hour to lift
through just one of our puny human
minutes
he's amazing it's how I'm saying let's
move on I'm going to gather a team with
special abilities see I believe enemies
are coming and stop right there I'm in
you are just like that yeah
I need friends right
keep this okay so we get this fun moment
with Barry Allen and I like that he's
such a fanboy and he asked if he can
keep the Batarang it might be fun if he
actually does keep the Batarang and use
it a safe Bruce later in the movie but
it's not just in the point out here that
he doesn't need friends because he's
kind of alone in the world they were
talking about the comic-con panel that
because Barry Allen moves so fast that
his ears can't hear sound waves he moves
faster than speed of sound so whenever
he moves really fast he's just moving
through a silent world and he feels
isolated but maybe here's his chance to
make some super friends know move on
[Applause]
nearing the end here we get kind of like
the epic shots of each member of our
team thus far few mine of course without
Superman because he's dead forever and
he's never coming back but what I want
to focus on here is flash actually watch
take a look at him notice how this
version of flash is very similar to the
version that we saw in injustice it's
got different pieces to it and he has a
similar look in fact it's actually very
different I think on purpose from the
Barry Allen on TV who's got the kind of
like leather look it looks like it might
have zippers hidden away there somewhere
this is like assembled armor because in
injustice everyone's worried about
dealing with Superman I'm also gonna
point out though this look and this
scary Superman from a Justice remember
this is all the same stuff that was
happening in that kind of wormhole
nightmare vision dream that happened in
Batman vs Superman that was Barry Allen
flash there - now the moments are
finally like connecting together it's
kind of funny to know that these two
have met before just in the future for
Barry Allen and in the past for Batman
but the world that they're headed toward
I still think they're setting this up
for who knows why I don't know if it's
like Justice League part 2 or 30 but
that cost him in the nod to injustice I
feel like we're still definitely headed
there at some point oh also uh who's
firing at him there's a red blast hmm
not saying Superman comes back in his
evil but maybe Superman comes back any
debo just saying maybe Oh check out this
shot of Aquaman with the ocean spray I
feel like that's also check out the shot
of Aquaman with like though it's like
the great grant apple juice okay what do
you think of that name from
also check out real quick the shot of
Aquaman also check out this shot of
Aquaman with like the oceans oceans
break quickly check out this shot of
Aquaman and for the ocean wits for Erik
and it looks like it's from the comics
they might be cycling the image from the
comics that's it oh all you had to say
moving on
about you didn't think you were real
realize useful so this could be a
massive ventilation shaft that like runs
all the way down to this tunnel that
connects metropolis and Gotham across
the bay and that all could be happening
underneath strikers islands you see in
the comics Strykers Island is a prison
Island but in Batman vs Superman they
actually showed it projectile 1 impact
Strykers Island east of Metropolis but
they turned it into kind of an
uninhabited island maybe there's an
abandoned prison there but that's where
the big doomsday showdown takes place so
in Justice League now they could be
taking a page from the comics and set
Strykers Island as a place where some of
these same team members actually need to
investigate the pending Darkseid
invasion oh and Silas stones cyborgs
father head of STAR Labs and the guy who
was playing with matey
a mother box in Batman vs Superman what
rumor has it that he could be missing in
this movie and this same place could be
part of the search for oh and speaking
of Batman vs. Superman at all remember
all those parademons we saw there those
are an army of creatures that they serve
Darkseid yada yada they're confirmed to
be in this movie and some descriptions
of them have them acting like that in
these new Justice League movies so
couldn't you just see a bunch of them
just hanging upside down like sleeping
and just ready to attack that would be
terrifying but also amazing also it'd be
ironic for Batman to have to deal with
them since it's usually pretty cozy with
bats and that last line we're about in
says it's interesting as it gets into
what Batman's whole MO is he prefers to
be a myth just to scare people into not
committing crimes but then he reveals
himself as the real deal when a job
needs to be done and right now a big job
needs to be done they need to take down
whatever this big threat is cool so
let's look at just the tag here at the
curry
here you can talk to fish
I kind of like this joke here at the end
cuz just does remind everyone like hey
you know how y'all were really concerned
about Aquaman looking like a loser and
being the lamest member of the Justice
League
this is Jason Momoa he could kill all of
us and yeah he can also talk to fish but
they're mostly calling out the people
that were worried about Aquaman being a
[ __ ] he's not anymore at least but
that's it for this trailer yeah it's uh
oh we noticed so if there's anything
that you noticed that we didn't call out
good job doesn't know what it is hit me
up on twitter at fimo and just let me
know if there's small things there you
can send me up on facebook facebook.com
slash fimo knows if there's a longer
diatribe you want to fill me in on also
you can hit me up on Twitter a da boss
or follow new rockstars on Twitter at
new rockstars for information about when
our videos are gonna be coming out thank
you so much our patreon supporters you
guys make it so that we can make these
videos if you're interested in
supporting this Eric Speicher on comm
slash me rock stars I'll check out that
a Wonder Woman breakdown it's also very
cool we found lots of interesting little
hidden nuggets there and subscribe if
you're not already cuz we're gonna hit
up a lot of comic-con stuff this week
and in the weeks to come otherwise I
think I'm done yeah me too thanks guys
[Music]